all right well uh welcome back everyone
so the next talk is going to be by uh
caribbean and it's going to be a
dequantization thought uh de-quantizing
the quantum singular value transform
partners and applications to quantum
chemistry and the quantum pcb conjecture
there's a lot going on in this title and
i'm actually super excited to find out
what it all means
great uh thanks so much for the
introduction scott um you were the first
person to actually read out the full
title because i didn't talk so i'm very
proud of you um i wish i had a prize um
okay good so uh thanks very much also
for the introduction uh for the
invitation too much um so this is going
to be joint work with hansa legal
this is essentially an extended version
of the the qip talk basically so we'll
go into more details and i'll be able to
tell you a little bit more about proofs
and things like this
so let's begin um by the way um really
naive question so this is a lattice's
quantum workshop so do the lattice
people know anything about quantum can i
assume this
is that fair okay if there's anything
you need to know along the way you just
let me know okay just stop and i'll
write stuff on the board
okay good
so uh the theme of this work is really
really closely related to some of the
things we saw this morning uh related to
quantum advantage right which is you
know where is the boundary between the
power of these two models of computing
right classical and quantum
and of course this is one of the the
driving questions of our field at least
from the cs side and it's a very broad
question so you know in this talk we're
going to sharpen this into three guiding
questions
okay
um so what do what exactly do we mean by
uh boundaries
okay so the first thing we care about is
we want to do things rigorously right um
as uh greg was saying we're kind of like
half mathematicians at the very least
like greater than or equal to right so
we'd like to do things rigorously and
nowadays we actually have really good
frameworks for doing this right over the
last few years they've been these really
nice quantum advantage frameworks which
you know try and make classical
computers look bad and quantum computers
look good
and then on the flip side this has been
this really nice
counter view of dequantization basically
which tries to make classical algorithms
look good and things like quantum
machine learning look bad okay
so that's one thing we'll touch on um
the next thing of course we care about
is you know um how can we define a
practically meaningfully such boundary
right um so of course in the long term
we'd probably do something like run
schwarz algorithm
right
but of course in the shorter term in
this in this nisk era right um
is there a task that would be actually
practically meaningful and useful okay
and uh scott already touched on a lot of
these things that we're going to be
going in the direction of quantum
chemistry here of course um and there
has been a very nice uh simon's
colloquium on by garnet channel on this
topic so i'll mention a little bit of
that later as well okay
and finally of course um anytime we have
any sort of boundary between the power
of cosplay and quantum computation um
you could always ask what does it say
about the physics of the underlying
models right
so for example there's this very
infamous quantum pcb conjecture right
which um has resisted efforts for years
and um you know one way to interpret
this conjecture if it holds is to say
that
natural quantum systems can be
exponentially complex even at high
temperatures
okay so in this work basically we take
these three guiding questions and we um
you know intertwine them into one
narrative that's the goal
and so on this slide here i'm going to
outline kind of the main points of this
work basically at an informal level
okay so we're talking about boundaries
between the power of cluster and quantum
computing so the first thing i need to
do is you know i need to define the
boundary right so what's the boundary
the boundary is going to be a practical
computational problem which i'll call
glh it's taken right out of quantum
chemistry okay
and
what you need to know about this problem
at this point is that you know for
quantum chemistry applications right the
precision to which you need to solve
this problem
is inverse polynomial in the length of
your system
okay so that's kind of the gold standard
you're going for
uh here we're assuming the hamiltonian
has been re-normalized
okay um so first of all formalize this
problem uh the next thing we'll do is
we'll show that um
if you're willing to give up some of
this precision right you're not gonna
solve this thing to really good
precision but only to this sloppy one
over uh constant position right
then you can actually solve this problem
efficiently classically
if you get to add to your computational
model these so-called sampling
assumptions which you know nowadays are
more or less becoming standard in our
field
and this is where we're going to see
this the quantization of the quantum
singular value transform
in this particular setting in the
setting of sparse matrices and constant
precision
okay
so that's a positive result
and then on the flip side again we want
this boundary between close point
quantum so this is the the classical
side of it the quantum side of it is
that if we go back to this one over poly
precision that chemists really care
about
then this problem is actually be hard to
solve in the worst case
okay
but and you know i'll say more about
what this means for quantum advantage
briefly
okay
and finally what does all of this say
about the quantum pc conjunction
good so any questions before we begin
that's where we're going
again feel free to stop me at any time
but so let's start by defining this
problem glh
so for those of you familiar with
hamiltonian complex you can probably
guess that the lh in uh glh stands for
the local hamiltonian problem okay
and so what is this problem in this
problem i'm giving you a local
hamiltonian h on uh
n qubits
okay
and um
your goal is to estimate the ground
state energy of this hamiltonian okay
the smallest eigenvalue here it is the
slam demand okay and you know is the
smallest eigenvalue at most some alpha
or is it at least some beta and the
point here is that there's some promise
of course
alpha and beta are not too close
together okay so they need to be at
least one over poly separated
okay so this is kind of the canonical
qma complete problem in quantum
complexity theory we've known that for
like 20 years now
and we know many hardness results in all
sorts of geometries and for various
physically motivated models
okay
good
let me briefly touch on this because
we're going to come back to the uh qp
speed conjecture later
so here i said it's very important that
the the promise gap is over poly
and you might ask you know what if we're
going to be sloppy here and ask for a
constant problem scout
and when you do that then you fall into
this regime of the so-called quantum pcb
conjecture
okay and here's conjecture that this
problem remains uh qma complete even if
you're sloppy you only estimate this
ground state energy to constant
precision
of course what we do know already is
that this problem certainly at least can
be hard because you can embed classical
csps into this framework okay in this
constant precision setting
okay any questions about the slide
because if you don't understand the
slide the rest of the talk will make no
sense
it's safe to assume everybody knows what
hamiltonian is
let me know if not
okay good so this is the local
hamiltonian problem right and
we've been studying this from a
theoretical perspective for two decades
now and you know
while you know we think we're important
people doing this you know in in the
actual real world right this is
supposed to be you know us
in theory land like sitting on the moon
and you know we're off staring into uh
what people are doing in the real world
you know chemists are trying to actually
solve this problem in practice
okay
okay and so what do they actually try
and do right to solve this problem well
i mean first let me refer you to this
really nice
simon's colloquium on april 12th so this
was a really nice talk by garnet chen it
was a little bit deflating perhaps right
i mean it was an honest talk but it's a
bit deflating about our prospects here
at least to date but this is essentially
what they do okay they um the first
things they do is that uh they want to
solve for these ground state energies in
quantum chemistry okay that's a very
important task
and so what they do is they first use a
classical heuristic
okay to try and compute a good uh
approximating ground state okay it's
it's it's not necessarily the ground
state but it's going to be some guiding
states
okay
now i want to be really really clear uh
number one that um first of all there's
no guarantee that a good classically
representable such approximate ground
state should even exist in the first
points that's not clear at all right
and these are not polytime algorithms
right they're heuristics
so let me be really really clear
so in some cases in practice i mean it
turns out that some of these heuristics
work really really well
right so here's uh there are some
examples but in general you're not
guaranteed that they're going to work
and this is really one of the things
that garnett really touched on in his
talk here
okay
good
so what do you do once you have this um
guiding state in your uh at your
disposal right
well
if i have a quantum computer at my
disposal right i have an approximation
to my ground state
and i just want to solve an eigenvalue
problem right so what am i going to do
you know the obvious thing right i'm
going to run phase estimation right
that's what we always do
and more recently there are these
variational approaches again this is
what carnet was really talking about
but it all fits into the same boat okay
and in this talk i'm not going to talk
about these variational approaches i'm
just talking about qpe okay we won't
really talk about qpe directly either of
course
okay so this is essentially what we want
to formalize as the glh problem so let
me do that
so this is the so-called guided local
hamiltonian problem
okay and this is the same definition as
before for the local hamiltonian problem
and what's new are these lines in red
okay so in addition to the to the
hamiltonian i'm also giving you some
representation of a guiding state psi
okay
and um a promise that this state has
some good overlap some delta overlap
with the ground space
some deltoid
and that's what makes the the reduction
not trivial i mean it's not hard to be
honest but it's also much like for that
reason yeah
so the heart frequent from the previous
slide um you said they got 99
that's what the business wrote in their
paper yes um but that's different to
what you have here right
um
that's that can be quite different
that's right so you can use um very
careful that's a very good point so for
example it's known that on dense
constraint satisfaction systems you know
product states are really good
approximations to get you the right
energy but they're not actually good
approximations to the ground state
itself
right um so some local observables can
be approximate well with that enzymes
but not all this right so that's not the
same as this right this is a stronger
promise in some sense absolutely so is
the sampling assumption going to be
something like that you can sample from
the output distribution of psi
sure yes
okay good good good i was wondering what
what that could mean in this context
i'll define it yeah all right thanks
thanks
okay so this is actually uh
is
not necessarily close energy not
necessarily
uh
uh large or enough state but but uh
getting states for which for which local
observables or that's right
that's a good question i'm not sure if
the answers to that question right um
but you're absolutely right right i mean
typically you just want to reproduce
some of the local insurance right that's
the goal
um
so what's the reason that you take this
condition
well it was one way to formalize it
right it's certainly one way before
right and presumably there are other
good ways as well right but you know
when you take on uh this definition then
you you can prove certain positive
negative results but on the flip side it
also makes it harder to find that bloody
thing right
it's harder to prove something with an
energy condition
[Music]
with an energy promised
condition
i'm assuming you'll be perfectly fine at
the projection on the blue and the
subspace is large instead of ground
space
oh yeah um
and you might just actually get that
right like if you want to use phase
destination
i mean um i mean but the fact that
you're about
right so you you already have a promised
cat oh yeah then in that case yeah so
sorry he's thinking more in the actual
practice setting where you don't have a
problem
for papers five
and then what so so is it just the
cables like four and three
okay so um
this is the original result showing
essentially quantitative thickness for
this problem and you know now we know
all sorts of things like even if you put
these things on a line um and they're
even translation and variants you can
get hardness results in there that has
nothing to do with the pcb setting
though right uh that's in the one more
public precision setting and the only
results we know in the constant position
setting are just if you embed classes on
multiples like diagonals basically
is two different assumptions
so for our results um
we can show that the problem will be um
relatively hard even if i give you a
constant delta here
right
or even if i can do a really like you
know three-quarter overlapping with the
ground state the classic computer
doesn't know what to do
um and i believe for the quantization
uh it's also going to be constant we
need all our parameters to be constantly
compensation
so all our results think of delta as a
constant
okay
yeah so um
you know we have to be very careful here
right i mean i'm saying i'm gonna give
you some representation of a guiding
state
right so what do i mean by that
obviously we can't write this thing down
explicitly and so we're gonna use two
classes of representations for this work
the first one is the so-called sampling
axis representation okay this is
obviously going to have to do with this
dequantization
and once we take this representation
which i'll define shortly we'll see that
this problem is going to be classically
solvable if basically all the parameters
are constant so constant position okay
constant overlap with the ground space
okay so that's the the positive result
um and here we say okay if we return to
that one over poly setting we want for
solving quantum chemistry problems
um the choice of representation we'll
use here is something even simpler it's
something called the semi-classical
state
and here we'll get uh bqp hardness okay
i mean these conditions don't even seem
mutually exclusive you know
if you have i'll define what this is but
once you have this you could certainly
implement this
oh okay so
so the issue is about the representation
yeah yeah because otherwise you would
have just proved that p equals b
all right all right
this representation is not so useful
explicitly direct hostile algorithm
generally speaking where we want to give
it some sort of sentence all right all
right all right all right it's fine it's
just fine so it's the two things and the
two results are both different
representations of the state
and uh and and and what about like if
alpha and beta are like you know and
delta like one over log like like what
what's going to happen
um re-quantization i think should end up
running a positive element as a
possibility
i mean you'll see the so it's so so
basically these like like one over these
parameters is going to show up in an
exponent essentially yeah so it's gonna
be like the sparsity of your matrix to
the the degree of the polynomial you
need to choose and that has to do with
this
all right all right
good
so this is the problem which we're going
to study this for the rest of the talk
um but before i do that let me just try
and tell you kind of what's the punch
line at this point okay and how does
this tie into this whole um you know
quantum advantage that was talked about
this morning
so we can show that um this problem to
within that one over poly precision is
bkp hard uh it's also in bqp because you
just run phase estimation
given a good guiding state and so you
know this problem glh or one over poly
precision perfectly characterizes what
it means to do you know efficient
quantum computation
and so you know the obvious um question
you want to ask yourself then is that
you know
is this a practically meaningful task to
experimentally demonstrate something
like quantum advantage
okay
now i've been very careful about this
right i've got this red question mark
here and
the the results we have here are worst
case results um so here when i say btp
hard there's not an average case
reduction it's a worse case reduction
right and so you know we're nowhere near
kind of the bar of hardness you really
want for these kind of advantage results
right typically you want to have average
case hardness also in the noisy setting
well i mean once something is beekeeping
hard then you could just combine it with
any like hard you know hard on average
instance of a bqp problem right and to
run the reduction and that'll give you
some distribution over instances right
maybe yeah maybe not natural for your
problem yeah yeah okay
by the way what does the boxing
hamburger represent
so
because everything's being recorded
nowadays i've been more careful about
sourcing my like pictures
and so there's a free source where the
only thing that came up when i wrote
punchline is this one
the first person to ask me this question
well that's the question right so here
you're crossing your fingers and hoping
these variational algorithms will do
their trick but you know as barnett's
talk gave away that
doesn't necessarily seem to be the case
and maybe i should make one point really
clear here right
um to to do this right there are two
parts to this right
there's getting your hands on that
guiding state the classical heuristics
and then there's the actual quantum side
of it which is saying energy
right so granite's talk was basically
saying that the first part of this
getting of the guiding state seems very
hard that's what i took away from
installing
and
um
i mean if you could build a large scale
conversation then you could certainly do
the phase estimation but i'm not i don't
know too much about the variation
algorithms to be honest you know what
you can expect out of those in terms of
estimating energy
yeah assuming you had a good benefit
so so really here you know this is a big
question mark i'm not this is not like
something that okay we should obviously
do this but you
what
precision scaling is important for
practical
applications
well so normally what you want is you
want like a there's some constant
precision you want um in the quantum
chemistry like um that's gold standard i
forget uh what the units work in this
psychological right
but what we do in this work is uh we
renormalize the hamiltonian so that is a
constant norm and therefore then you're
looking at one more quality position
okay the system size right whereas
normally in chemistry they don't need to
re-normalize they just want constant
irrespective of the electrolysis
so that's why we have one more
um okay this is what i was just saying
this is worst case complexity um
i'll bug you more about what you're
saying after
an interesting time let me just go
okay
good so for the hardest result right i
need to tell you what is this
representation of the state side of what
is the semi-classical state
and so this is a really really simple
classic space there's nothing fancy here
um basically it's a special case on what
alex willow and co-authors
call subset states
okay and all it is is basically you pick
a subset s of strings and you give me
the equals to the position
okay
what's different in our setting versus
railroad is that our subset is poly size
and so this ensures that the state psi
has a really simple class construction
but and so what we can show here
basically is that you know even if you
give me essentially constant overlap
with the ground space okay if you want
this precision uh then this problem is
fine
you need to simulate a quantum computer
so
anytime it's at 3 30 30. that works yeah
but so i'll
cut out as i go to make instead
okay so um the perp sketch basically how
do we make this work this is not a
difficult thing to be clear um there's a
little bit of trickery that's needed
however
what you want to do is you want to take
an arbitrary computation right
and you want to map it to an instance of
glh basically so that you have two
things here right number one is you know
this is kind of the usual one out of
this right so if you accept its input
then the graphing energy is small if you
reject graphs the energy is large that's
very easy to get
okay that's uh what's this point you're
just plugging in findings um make a type
circuit california construction
what's a big trick here to get is that
we have to design this guidance
okay
and so this is where we do a bit more
work in the reduction
okay
so let me tell you a little bit about
how this goes um to tell you a bit about
how this goes well
okay let me why don't i just go to the
sampling part
and then if i have time i'll come back
to this
so uh the trick of course is that in the
no case uh
it's hard to design that well not hard
but it's not immediately trivial how to
design the guiding state and there are
various ways you can get around this
basically and so so we use some of the
trickery from understand minus but if
there's time i'll come back to this
later let's put it out you know i'd
rather you guys take the time to ask any
questions
good so let me tell you about the the
quantization aspect then
make sure we cover this
okay um so in this um
result basically we're going to give you
a sample statement what do i mean by
that um so there's a big nasty
definition on the slide
um just ignore this zeta parameter zeta
is kind of a noise parameter for us and
it basically says that okay i'm allow i
you can tolerate some error some noise
data in your sample okay but imagine a
perfect sampling so zetas zero
and so really just focus on these two
okay what does it mean to have sampling
access to some gigantic state psi it
means two things
okay number one
you give me an index right and i assume
there's some efficient way to compute
the amplitude psi i and poly time
okay so it's just the usual query access
model
and this alone to a classical computer
is pretty useless right i mean there's a
giant vector right um i have polytime
you know where am i supposed to look in
this vector i have no idea
and that's where the sampling axis comes
in
right this basically says that um
i can figure out what are the heaviest
elements in my vector in some sense okay
so i can sample from a distribution p
right and this distribution what it does
is it returns an index into your vector
and that index the odds of seeing that
index really just scale with
the norm squared of that entry
okay so the heaviest elements are most
likely to get sampled
so this allows us to zoom in on those
heavy elements
so when zeta is zero this is literally
just tang's definition from her
breakthrough work on dequantization okay
questions about this definition
can't tolerate all zeta like there is
some threshold
i don't remember exactly what we got to
be honest with you
but i think you can tolerate certain
constants here
right and how big the constant got it
okay so um how do we um so what's the
name here we show here here we show that
if all your parameters are constant
basically then you can solve this
problem in poly and time
okay
and what's the the sketch of the proof
basically um these are the main
components you know i won't have time to
tell you about all of them but the basic
premise is this
you want to solve
an eigenvalue problem right
so the first thing you do is you reduce
it to a singular value problem i mean
that's kind of natural you would expect
that to happen okay and of course this
is also in the guided setting
okay and so also constant precision
and once you have this uh this is where
you do this dequantization uh trick
basically um
and here we show that you can
de-quantize the so-called sparse quantum
singular value transform again in the
constant precision setting
okay and then to kind of plug this back
in here we won't have to process our
hamiltonian with some polynomial p
and what's really important here is that
because i'm only worried about solving
it in the constant precision setting
then this polynomial can be constant
degree
okay and this this degree is what's
going to show up in the runtime this is
back to your question
okay so let me tell you about this step
of the proof
okay so for this let me define what i
mean by quantum well just singular value
transform for this discussion
okay so this is a pretty nasty
definition but you know i'm just going
to
ask you to focus here basically
okay so what are we given as input we've
got
a matrix a which is sparse s bars
okay
and we are given a polynomial p which is
even
and then let's just imagine for now
we've got two vectors v and u um to
which we get sampling axis
and your goal is to do this basically
take the singular value
transformation of a or the composition
of a and then
apply this polynomial to the singular
values you can think of it that way
okay and once you do that i need to
output a scalar so then you take the
inner product with these two vectors to
which which are given as part of the
input to which we assume we have
sampling axis
and your job is to estimate this
quantity to some additive error epsilon
for us epsilon is constant
okay you'll notice there's absolutely
nothing quantum about this right the
quantum singular value transform
algorithm what it does is it basically
produces this state right i mean given
this uh a state u it produces this this
product
okay so in that sense this will
dequantize that algorithm
in this setting not in all settings of
course right let me be clear
okay so
ah here's the data we tolerate back to
your question right
for us epsilon is constant so at most
one over eight is is what we can achieve
good uh this is the run time this is
scott scotch question uh there's a
degree
okay
but so how do we do this
so the proof is very natural okay it's
also very similar to what actually tang
does in her work okay and if you've seen
like um these earlier works on like
randomized linear algebra this is very
similar to what they do
okay
so here's the idea right i'm trying to
approximate this thing given sampling
axis let's say to v and u
and so what do i have well i've got an
inner product right
so what's an inner product well you know
i just take for example i have a big sum
right and then i take the i the entry of
this vector and the ith entry of this
vector and i multiply them together and
then i add them to my big sum that's an
inner product
and of course what's difficult here is
that you know these vectors are
exponentially long
so since we have this very nice sampling
axis to v however right i know where the
heaviest elements are right so i can use
that in a random experiment right so
what i'll do is
i'll just pick our random entries out of
v using the sampling access
and do the following okay so like i said
that's very natural repeat this some r
times which just depends on the area you
want
okay so what i'll do is um first i have
sampling access to this so let me just
pull out the jth
index on the left-hand side okay and
then once i have the index according to
its weight
i can compute the corresponding entry
region
okay and on the right-hand side this is
slightly non-trivial there's a recursive
step you have to take here but the point
is that given just query access to u
it turns out that i can compute the jth
index of this w
and here what's really really important
is the fact that a is sparse
okay
that's very important
and finally you know this is just um you
know you add this running total to your
average you've got to do some
appropriate rescaling because i'm only
taking a very small number of samples
out of my entire inner product
and apply the chebyshev's inequality and
you know presto you'll see that you'll
be within
the air bounds you want
good problems
okay so again it's arguably quite
natural
um so over here this tells us how to do
this okay we can de-quantize this um
there's this one other step uh in
between that allows us to go from here
to here basically
now let me tell you just briefly about
what this is doing what the step is for
and it's going to have to do the fact
that you know i'm going to allow any
choice of constants in my input
okay
so so basically the idea is that um you
can you know
rather simply modify a polymer
construction from low end triangle right
to get a constant degree polynomial that
basically does this very nice processing
of the singular values of the matrix for
you
okay so basically what it's going to do
is it's going i'm looking for you know
i've given i'm being given a range a to
b
is there a singular value in that range
okay
and what this thing will do is that when
you process these singular values with
this polynomial kind of tear apart the
singular values so everything in this
range gets mapped approximately to one
okay
and everything that's not in that range
gets mapped approximately to zero
okay so now it's it's very easy for me
to tell if there was something in this
range because well now they're quite far
apart
and so even if i have a sloppy
approximation to my ground state i can
still distinguish whether i'm in this
case or this case essentially or it's my
corresponding singular vector i should
say
so once you have that basically then you
just run that dequantization algorithm
on the processed version of your matrix
questions
it still works it's just that the
runtime goes to super quality
over here
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that and in fact i was asking about this
like in terms of
it's like here um
if you want whatever poly precision
um then the three of your polymer has to
grow as well as
that's the problem because i mean
you're trying to resolve like a very
small slice of the singular values now
it's like longer poly wide and so this
polynomial you can imagine that it needs
to kind of fluctuate quite a lot in some
sense it can't just be something
going back to scott's question so if you
have a log you should define it the
polylog is a problem right
yeah okay yeah yeah so then you get a
quasipoly
oh it's a simple log
many physical setup yeah i mean the
degree does need to increase with the
respect
right because uh your hamiltonian norm
grows with respect to the system size
you want to have constant precision so d
i'm just saying that
yeah for many physical components such
as the local deposit sure the norm of
the hamiltonian growth with respect to
the citizen site
that's right you want some constant
procedure that's right yeah so here's
the word no no no no okay sorry i should
clarify this yeah
i'm sorry not you many people want
constant procedure that's right with
respect to this unknown myself yeah yeah
yeah that's right yeah and then this
thing really
oh yeah
okay so let me see um what this says
about quantity basically
okay so um the quantum pcb conjecture um
just basically says that
this local hamiltonian problem when the
threshold or the level of precision you
want um if it's not one over poly but if
it's constant we believe that this
should still be q my heart
and so what we can show is that you know
once you have this dequantization under
your mouth basically it's not very
difficult to adapt that to show that
exactly in this regime right in this
quantum pcb regime
you know if you're promised that there's
a good um guiding state that has the
sampling property
well then this quantum basically theorem
just canceled
because you could you know verify that
thing in real martha
okay so obviously nobody in their right
minds i think expects this thing to
exist in general to have a good guiding
state with this property
and so
can you prove that it doesn't exist
right and right now we can't
uh and so we just turn it into a
conjunction
right and so we'll literally rip off
this very nice nlts conjecture of
freedom in hastings
and you know what this really says is
that you know if you believe the quantum
pcb conjecture
then there has to be a family of uh
local hamiltonians
okay uh and and some constant epsilon
so that basically the low energy space
of this hamiltonian you know should not
have a nice classical description
okay which uh specifically they looked
at quantum constant depth quantum
circuits
okay and so you know if you just take
this definition literally and just copy
paste and just change the representation
of the state um you can get what we call
the analysis conjecture and here we're
positing that you obviously should not
have a state
that has good sampling access okay
because otherwise
our results on the previous slide would
say that in this constant error
regime
the verification of that problem would
not be qma hard it would fall into ma
so so then you just got qmi equals mmi
i said
so
i guess i have a few minutes left yeah
yeah okay i can go back to the to the
beach for a second i don't want to say
too much about it but
then it wasn't so bad um
so what do i really want to tell you
here um
so on this bqb hardness proof we wanted
to take a a bqpp circuit u and embed it
into a hamiltonian for one of these glh
instances right and
in the s case um whenever you have um
i won't go through this in any serious
detail right but the point is that um
in the us case when you do this
reduction right there is a good guiding
state or there's a good state you can
copy at least to design your guiding
state right and so the so-called history
state which embeds basically the
behavior view okay into a low energy
state
and so you can play various kind of
standard tricks to make it so that
something very simple essentially the
initial state of your computation
is going to be a very good approximation
to that history state
here you play that really stupid trick
where um
i can take my circuit right it's got m
gates in it and if i just kind of double
the length of that circuit and use
identities as the first half of that
competition this idling trick then um
you know essentially i know exactly what
half the weight in this history state
looks like it's just a trivial start
state
good so that's how you design the s case
the slightly trickier thing is that in
the note case
typically we don't have this history
state to guide us
right so how do you design this guiding
states when you don't know what the
ground state looks like or the ground
space looks like
and so here we use this really cute
trick of anderson minus and here he was
studying something completely different
you know this is kind of relating back
to omisha's question about
estimating local observables the right
complexity class for this turns out to
be not qma but p to the q may lock
and so what is this cute little gadget
he has
basically it allows you to
design um the reason why we use this is
it lets us design the ground space in
the no case
okay and how does this work it's
basically here
so essentially i'm gonna have a block
diagonal encoding okay so this is the
hamiltonian that comes out of the pitaya
construction when you plug in your
circuit view
okay and i tag that with the one
and in the other block i just put in
something trivial about it's the
identity but it's designed set the the
energy here is strictly between the two
problems parameters
okay and so why does this help us well
um
if the ground's the energy of the
hamiltonian is small
okay
then for sure since the minimum
eigenvalue here is alpha plus beta over
two
here will be at most alpha this is
smaller now and so i know the ground
space is here and then i know that um
in the s case
now i'm in the s case right then i know
that i'm in the s case i'm over here and
so i can simulate that history state
okay and so this will be a good guiding
state
this here is the history state from the
previous slide
and in the null case when my ground
state energy is at least beta for this
guy
then the the smallest eigenvalue is
actually hiding here because this has an
eigenvalue smaller than b
and here this is a trivial space right
it's just the identity okay so
everything is an eigenvector here
so i can use that exact same psi
history state approximation and the only
thing is i need to tag it with a zero
rather than a one because it's in this
block and that's why you see this plus
here
so it's a very simple guiding state
okay so
that's all i have to say about this any
last questions
yes
no i don't think so um because like um
you i think you need to know the
classical proof
in advance
uh
correct
for harvest
yeah
how do you do the reduction uh well how
do i get the guiding state right
every stage is just the witness like the
the witness if you don't know what it is
but the approver can provide it to you
yeah
but uh okay sorry
um
did i say this is specified beforehand
right
okay
part of the promise
i mean i see what you mean yeah i mean
you can imagine that the qcp version
where i give you a claim dividing state
yeah but then now there's a question how
do you verify this
uh if it's a subspecies
[Music]
yeah then you could uh see if it's good
enough to get this album that's right in
that case so then it would really depend
on the representation yeah
other questions
oh that's a good question okay yeah so
in the previously quantization results
like that
that that's that means low rank setting
that's right so here we get in the
sparse setting and
the reason i mean the only thing we
really need is um
so the actual quantization but
the procedure
where we go here right
um basically this thing over here it
doesn't the only thing that property it
needs for age
right it doesn't care about the rank of
it just cares about the sparsity
and intuitively this is the reason why
right um if a is sparse okay let's say
it's a polynomial of um
elements per row right then classically
if you have query access to you then you
can figure out what this product is
going to be because you only need to
look at the poly number of entries in
this matrix
but if it's not sparse and it's loranga
i'm not sure how like this approach
doesn't seem like it'll work at all
to me it looks very different right so
in some sense this is like really simple
right it's just using the fact that a is
mostly zeros right
and then you can just very explicitly
kind of do the inner product yourself
um
is
is
[Music]
yes so
yeah basically i mean here um
what basically i'm going to talk about
this is like here you have a
class where you're making queries with
your network so the question is how do
you embed that into like a history state
construction and you know it turns out
the way to do it or at least one way to
do it is um by using this gadget where
you kind of have this block diagonal
space where intuitive this is encoding
the answer to become inquiry so this is
in the yes case you know here in this
block and another place here in this
block
and so this is a simple a simpler
version of this because in this case
there's a long number of
queries all right um anyone else
all right
something about about this guy these
stages
uh yeah i asked friends a lot about this
uh
i don't think so i don't think we have
any like formal linker
yeah that's right for these like workout
chain
simulation operations yeah absolutely
that's right that's what the first thing
i thought of in fact
[Music]
but maybe i'll take a very quick moment
to do some
disciplines here
uh shameless self-promotion um a number
of people asked us for this paper we
talked about it character 22. it's
finally up today so i'm here this week
if you want to talk about this this is a
totally different topic uh this song
form space complexity and things like
savage's theorem are unentangled proof
system so if this kind of thing
interests you and you're also welcome
to talk to them
[Music]